hello everybody okay guys i woke up a little bit uh because
like i woke up and then i was like wait a minute where's my
room where's my where's my good night dragon's room because
like um so You know how I'm on a new PC.
So, because of that, I forgot to...
Some of the assets I forgot to move.
What is it being?
The room I broke into.
You know, the room I'm borrowing for Good Night Dragoons.
So, that was, like, six minutes of me trying to find...
You know, because, you know, I'm directionally challenged.
So, I didn't bring my map with me to find this room.
again the map was in my old pc and so like i had to get
google maps and try to figure out like where is this room
that broke into for good night dragoons i also sort of got
ahead a head start in the good night part because uh i took
a nap i took it i'm so tired i got i got a little head start
with the good night part and started eating but Before I did
the good night stream.
So yeah.
I'm sorry.
I'm so tired.
Are you eating?
Yes.
I woke up.
And I was like.
I like dragged myself out of.
Okay.
And then like I woke up.
Fucking stun locked by my alarm because I get the my alarm I
know I shouldn't have this as my alarm because it's like you
know It's it gives people like PTSD, but it works.
Yes, I know it gives people PTSD Because it's like the worst
alarm alarm in the world, but it works So my alarm is
literally the classic Apple alarm, you know the one that was
like Like that one.
I mean, I could play it right now and give you guys PTSD if
you really want to hear it.
Like the ones that are like right now trying to like use
this stream as just...
No!
Toki, this is supposed to be.
Good night, Dragon.
No, don't do it.
Okay, okay.
All right.
By my side.
No, Toki.
I won't put you, I won't put you through that, but yes, I
use the, I use the PTSD alarm to, to, to wake myself up,
because it fucking works, like, of course I would use it,
like, yes, I know it's terrible, but, like, terrible, even
though it's terrible, it works, you can't deny that it wakes
you up, uh, D-Dragon, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, silly dokey, this is good night, dragoons, not good
morning, Dragon's Thank you, the super chat Thank you, thank
you Anaya Thank you, the super chat Thank you, thank you I
couldn't catch up Before One of Can't catch one of the three
First three From bad luck So this is a fun Hello and reunion
Once Thank you for the Super chat Thank you, thank you Oh,
wow Okay, Various Does not give a fuck About you So does
Mike Nova Nova's just like Please five more minutes Thank
you Give it a super chat.
Thank you.
Nova 1.
It's silence.
But various and Mike are chaotic evil.
All right.
Let me.
See you guys.
Stopped my lo-fi.
You know what's coming up now.
Apple.
Alive.
Okay.
Where is it?
Is this one?
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I don't even know if it's this one.
No.
This is the soft one.
Apple Alive.
alarm.
Uh, what is it called?
Uh, alarm.
No, that is the, that's the nice one.
What's the name of it, guys?
That's the standard one.
Do you guys remember the name of it?
I don't remember the name of the alarm.
Is this one?
No, that's just an alarm clock.
That's just the alarm.
Don't tell it!
Oh, is it the nuclear?
Yeah, okay.
Is this one?
Alright.
Which one is the one that I have?
Is this?
Oh, this is it.
This is my alarm.
Wake up!
There you go.
Free alarm voice pack for you guys.
Wake up, dragons!
Wake up!
yeah yeah that's it that's my alarm so you guys have guys
you literally guys got i got a free alarm voice back guys
congratulations for free well not for free some of the
dragoons kick uh kick fun uh was it crowd fun
leon thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um
stop please Anyway, this was, this is my alarm.
Too late.
It already stopped.
The alarm is too quiet.
You should play again.
But way louder.
Remember, this is, this is an employee of my team.
He's literally gets paid to tell me to put it loud.
Be careful, sound guy.
That's how revolts, sir.
evil sound god no you're supposed to be for the people what
happened sound god
anyway um wake me up i need to work and um what was that yes
i was gonna say i am eating something right now i am eating
uh so for those who don't know what it is i'm trying to
remember what the English name is again is a mango pomelo
sago.
So basically it is a it is a famous Hong Kong dessert It's
actually one of my favorite desserts in the world.
So and I woke up.
I dragged myself to My PC and then my dad just got home and
he was like, oh, hey, do you want Yonzi Kamdong?
We just bought it.
I was like, yes Yes, I want it Um, uh, think of a super,
okay, wait, I want to make sure I say your name correctly.
Grabbing up my Google Translate because I can't read any
language, let alone English.
I can't read English.
Sato, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Doc, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, you pay your mods?
Yes, I pay my mods now.
If you guys didn't know, um, I recently started paying my
mods starting.
I think like was it last month um I don't remember some of
my mods can any of my mods can like uh fact check me but
like I started paying my mods I think like last month or the
month before uh because I make enough to pay them now uh
we're like I make um and it's because you guys that I can
provide like you know I can actually provide like uh uh
provide money for my mods uh to Let them keep doing what
they're doing.
So, yes, they do get paid now.
And they used to do this work for free.
Oh, the goodness of their hearts.
And because they are, they love working for me.
And now, now I pay them.
Because I think they still love working.
And now I pay them because it's Stockholm syndrome now.
Now I can never leave.
Thank you for the 20 get the ships.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, they get they get yelled at by me and they get paid.
Now you can't leave.
Yeah, they're too deep to leave now.
So yes, they do get paid.
Yay.
I know like it's not really like a common thing to do like
paying your mods.
Because like I said, like, you know, you have to be able to,
to be able to do so because there's always like there's so
many other expenses going on behind the scenes um but
luckily finally i am able to like uh i guess like uh be able
to do all these projects be able to uh do all these projects
plan all these things uh all my expenses and also pay my
mods because you see them here almost every stream and i
really appreciate it I really appreciate them being there
every stream And doing so many things for me You know,
advertising Reminding me to advertise stuff Because I always
forget My mods always reminding me about like obligations
that I have to do Like, you know Be like, hey guys Remember
that I'm sponsored by YouTubes and gamer subs I always
forget to say stuff like that Don't worry, my mods got me
They post, they give us like reminders and everything in
chat which is great uh so yes and then we have sound guy who
does like sound checkup like i always say i say i think that
like one of the most important things you need to have when
it comes to like if you want to be a streamer and have good
sound quality like like the first thing people would look at
is if like the sound quality is okay like the audio
balancing and stuff is okay because what's the moment if the
audio balancing not great they leave they leave the stream
because I hate watching streams with bad audio balancing so
I assume you guys would hate it too that's why I have a
dedicated sound guy and I always like give them like uh like
my feedback to give my sound guy my feedback being like hey
I think I prefer like if like if we continue doing this game
if I do a part two I prefer the game sound was a little bit
louder or like I didn't like how the game sound was louder
than me so could you like balance that in regards to that
next time because like they get to know my preferences and
everything um so yeah the sound guy gets yelled at me almost
like every other show the sound guy sort of uh get scolded
by me every like every two to three streams uh so they
deserve to get paid
Yeah, but they get paid, so it's fine, so it's okay.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Jurassic, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
Mod payment, I really appreciate it, thank you.
No, don't get, no, don't get, don't get,
but yeah.
Also, I sort of Okay, it wasn't low key Because that tweet
got a lot of traction But I sort of like Revealed that The
whole year Technically is Booked with events Or projects or
sponsors So every month There's something to look forward to
Guys I know I said fully booked But Hey guys if you want to
sponsors I know I said it's fully booked but I might let you
guys sneak into the calendar because I can't say no if I can
slide you right in
fully booked with exceptions
like i said the reason why um i know like i saw like people
were like don't keep please please rest you there's so many
announcements when do they stop you gotta rest stop when do
you mean stop it's the dokey year it's the year of the dokey
what do you mean stop if you think those are all the
conventions i'm gonna go this year guys it says world tour
there's a specific there's some there's a region that i
haven't listed yet in terms of conventions guys we have
conventions for na we have conventions
a region that we haven't announced yet.
That's like, you know, you know, there's no conventions
announced yet for a region.
And I did say World Tour.
Okay, I'm sorry, Latin America.
I don't want to get your hopes up, and I don't want to lie.
I'm sorry.
What's up, America?
I have to, like, I saw a lot of people very excited in South
America, but like, I'm sorry, guys.
I have to let you guys down right now.
Doki, no!
You said World Tour, Doki!
What do you mean?
Guys, all I'm saying is like, guys, you gotta get
conventions to invite me there, guys.
I think a lot of conventions in Latin America don't know who
I am.
I haven't got any invite from Latin America.
I'm so sorry.
If I had, if I get an invite, I would say yes.
Guys, I would say yes if I get an invite over there, but I
don't think I got a single invite yet.
I'll say yet because maybe, maybe next year or the end of
the year, it'll be different.
gonna guys i had to like let i had to let like a
self-america down i don't i don't want to get their hopes up
i'm so sorry but other than that there's a region excluding
self-america i'm very sorry i'm very sorry that we haven't
that we haven't announced a convention for it yet so keep
because there's more announcements coming.
Squibbly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Crys in Spanish.
Z-Py, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
How do you feel about onion rings or ring pop?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I mean, onion rings are pretty, um, uh, pretty goaded.
I like onion rings.
I haven't had a ring pop in so long.
I think it's because it's like, it's like super sweet.
I haven't had a ring pop in like, a long time i don't like
candy i'll share say i'm not a big fan of candy i prefer
chocolate more than candy the only types of candy i like is
cotton candy but only like cotton candy ice cream um i like
i can't have like like i don't know it's just it's just i'm
not a huge fan of like um candies in general i just think
it's like way too sweet so i prefer i prefer just chocolate
i like milk chocolate but then people will call me a loser
for liking milk chocolate, but I am not afraid to tell you
what I like.
I'm not, I'm here to represent the milk chocolate gang.
You'll say people who like milk chocolate are losers, but I
don't care.
I might be the biggest loser out there, but I will defend
milk chocolate.
Thank you.
But we have money.
They give them a chanta soup.
But they might say milk chocolate is for babies.
But I know what I like.
I hate dark chocolate.
Fuck dark chocolate.
That is my controversial statement of the day.
That is my hate statement of the day.
Fuck dark chocolate.
It wishes it was as good as milk.
chocolate.
I don't know, dark chocolate is healthy for you because the
darker the chocolate, the more cocoa in the chocolate, the
more health benefits you get.
You can try and cancel me, but I know what I like.
It's okay to be wrong.
No dark chocolate.
It does.
I just don't, it's just bitter.
It tastes bitter.
I just don't like dark chocolate.
It tastes so bitter.
I mean, it doesn't matter if it's healthier.
I'm not eating chocolate to be healthy.
Like, what the fuck is chocolate?
Like, chocolate is, like, the cheap food.
Why am I eating chocolate to be healthier?
I eat what I want to eat to, like, be like, I want to eat
something sweet today.
You're tasting the wrong one.
Look, it's okay to be wrong.
I'm thinking of a super chat Thank you, thank you It's okay,
you're still my Oh she even that's higher Say Thank you, I'm
a super chat Thank you, thank you It's okay to be wrong I
mean, I'm right, obviously Yes, okay Yes, I know Milk
chocolate Is cheaper but I am the I am for the people I'm
not the bourgeoisie
that's why I am for the people that's why I like real
chocolate more than dark chocolate I am for the people dark
chocolate just tastes better I mean yeah if you don't have
Yeah, if you don't have enough taste buds, I guess you can
see.
I'm gonna start a chocolate war.
Um, Borg, thank you for the five gift of chips.
Thank you.
I like how this is where I cross the line by talking dark
chocolate.
By being a milk chocolate like by having milk chocolate.
That's my oh she this is the line where it's crossed This is
where dragoons feel attacked
That was the moment the downfall of dokey bear when she gave
her opinion on chocolate But yes, that is what I prefer And
then like if you like regular like Like, I guess, like, and
then there's some freaks that like, like, the medium between
the two, like regular chocolate.
Like, why?
Why?
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Um, I think it's funny.
Have you guys, you know, like, what was it?
The Mr. Beast feastables?
Apparently, okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Mr. Beast is so fucking rich.
Like, the fact that he just threw money at it and managed to
convince a giant population of children to think that
feastables.
chocolates like taste good by the way mr.
base please invite me to your video I'll play Minecraft for
you mr.
beast if you send me a package of feast of buzz don't worry
my calendar is open for you mr.
beast so if you want to send me you know i see you sending
content creators you know feastable feastable chocolates and
like you know i can easily change my opinion you know yeah
you know i won't call it a bribe but like i mean everybody
loves free stuff
um geo thank you for the super chat thank you thank you Who
like dark chocolate are old people milk chocolate is the
bet.
I didn't say that That was Gio's opinion.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I didn't say that That was Gio's opinion.
I mean her opinion is right, but like I didn't I didn't say
that
Like it's not my opinion though Black thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you uh unfollows my mutual uh no you know like i
sometimes i don't don't know where old people you know like
old people will always have like the the old people candy
like the the strawberry wrapped candy and then like the
caramel where do they get those how do you like all the
elderly just know exactly what to buy
The grandma candies, yeah.
Like, yeah, the hard caramel.
And then, like, those strawberry-wrapped...
Those, like, strawberry-wrapped...
Like, not strawberry.
Like, you know, like, those candies that have, like, a
strawberry wrappings?
Those ones?
Where do they get those?
The dollar store?
There's no way.
There's no way grandmas are giving us dollar store candy.
I feel like every elderly person just knows exactly.
um like we're we're to get those candies um uh oh my gosh
there's something else i want to talk about when it came to
candy sorry uh my brain is like still waking up it's like i
need to rev my brain up right i need it oh but you know okay
there's one i really uh really miss um people uh people live
in asia might know what i'm talking you know like siton you
know that that shit was so good That and the rabbit one.
I don't remember what the rabbit candy is called.
So like, there's like two candies I really, like they're
actually like my favorite candies.
Like I know I'm not like a huge fan of candies, but like if
I see like Lysiton and the rabbit one, the rabbit one, like
I love that shit so much.
Yes, the white rabbit.
Yeah, that shit is so good.
Okay.
All right.
For those who don't know about it or like don't live in Asia
or never seen it in like Asian market, you guys should
really try.
these candies are so fucking good there's that's like
literally my childhood I don't eat it anymore because like I
don't eat candy I don't eat candy anymore but like if it
does show up I will like you know I look take one I'll take
a piece then licey uh candy and there's licey candy oh my
gosh How do you...
Wait, is it...
Red...
Uh...
Pocket Candy?
What's it called in...
In English?
Oh, it is!
It's called...
Chinese Good Luck Candy.
Okay, this shit is fire.
That shit is actually so good.
Alright, yes, it's JPEG.
Okay, I'll post it.
I can show it on screen too.
Alright, guys.
You guys gotta try this.
It's actually fire.
This shit is like so fucking...
good um it's honestly like one of my favorite uh candies in
the in the world i don't eat it as much anymore like i
barely eat candy these days but uh but like this shit is
really good it's called in english apparently it's called uh
chinese good luck candy i like how it's called chinese good
luck candy i like how it says good luck candy guys if you
eat it you get more good luck there's another one and this
one's like white rabbit candy um it's called creamy candy uh
please uh don't pay attention to the I know it's very uh
weirdly named I know it's it's a little the name is a little
bit like inappropriate but like trust me it's don't focus on
the creamy candy part focus on the white rabbit
focus focus on rabbit i didn't realize this was also the
name um carlos thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you that smug smile on my skin suit is really cute also milk
chocolate for what i told you i'm full of the people white
chocolate's the best okay but like okay i'll tell you guys a
story um there's a reason also why i don't eat this anymore
because it's also associated with like low-key traumatic
experience because I like but like I like this candy too
much so what happened was that um younger dokey was quite
impulsive little little child dokey it was a very impulsive
individual and like somebody left this bag candy out in the
open while i was uh visiting i think i was visiting my aunt
or some shit so like um um so little little dokey was a very
impulsive not anymore of course i'm different now of course
guys but little dokey was very impulsive so you know okay so
like the thing about this particular uh the thing about this
particular type of candy is that it's very chewy and sticky
so you know what little dokey did little dokey i don't know
how many i had but i stuffed my mouth with like at least
four to five plus once and set up you know sucking it like
uh nor how you normally do with hard candy i started chewing
and and when you chew it gets stickier so what happened to
little dokey is that um so i had silver teeth i don't know
if i still i think i still do But like I had silver teeth
instead of braces Because I don't know if this is like an
Asian thing But like I knew like back then instead of
getting braces People would get like silver like casings
over it Yeah like they'll put like silver casings over like
the tooth So um so What happened?
Yeah, the silver jackets.
It's like not even like silver.
It's like they're like jackets over a tooth instead of
braces.
Uh, were for cavities.
Oh, I didn't realize it was for cavity.
I thought they were for...
I was told they were for braces.
Well, anyway, I was a bad child.
That explains a lot, actually.
Okay.
Anyway.
That explains a lie that they were actually for cavities.
Anyway, so, so yes, I started chewing and yeah, I chewed the
candy.
And the jacket got stuck on the candy and it got off.
It got the casings.
got off the tooth because of the candy so little doki
despite loving white rabbit she doesn't eat a lot of that
candy anymore i still remember the moment because i was very
little doki but because it was a long time ago but i still
remember that moment it's like there's like flashball
memories So if you guys don't know, a flashbulb memory is
basically a moment that's so traumatic that you'll always,
you'll be like 90 years old and you'll still remember that
day.
This is my flashbulb memory.
It is my core memory.
So yes, little dokey doesn't eat a lot of candy anymore.
Adult dokey also doesn't eat a lot of candy anymore.
white rabbit candy I'll have one I'll these yes of course
they do it's famous I'll have like one not five plus like I
used to the candy trauma that's this is also why I'm more so
of a of a chocolate gal now I I only really have chocolate
instead of uh um instead of candy one is enough for me
yeah um it just reminds me when i used to live in asia uh
people don't celebrate halloween and like i had to the only
place you can go like trick-or-treating is like you so like
i used to go to international schools yeah so like told you
guys about this um i used to go also because only other
reason why there's no like there's no like places there's no
like trick-or-treating uh it's because a lot uh houses are
expensive like people don't normally live in houses in the
city in asia because like i think it's also because there's
no actual like there's no suburbia like you don't there's no
actual suburbia in um in asia it's just apartments it's just
mostly just apartment buildings and yeah there's not a lot
of space and everything so it's just like usually there's no
room for it it's just apartments if you live in a house in
Asia you're rich as hell or you live on the countryside uh
because like property is much cheaper there because there's
also like usually there's no internet uh there's no really
internet there so like property is a lot cheaper so yeah so
like if you live in a house you're fucking loaded you're
like an actual millionaire um so uh yeah more like you have
you're living in like uh you live in an area where there's
it's not really a city um uh anyway anyway so there's no
Halloween there's no trick-or-treating because uh there's
like you can't really trick-or-tree um in like a part like
you know you can't really trick-or-tree buildings it's just
apartments so it was really funny so i used to go to
international school yeah so uh i used to go to
international schools and in one of my international school
um they basically uh so that i guess like the americans
don't get culture shock um it's so when i think about it um
when you okay it's really funny but like uh i went to
international school and one of them they want to make sure
like i guess like the americans don't get culture shock with
like you know the no halloween stuff like that or like uh
they built their own suburbia for the school so like the
school uh was located in its own gated community where it
was like literally like like all the majority of the the
american families would live there because it would be like
their own suburbia obviously i wasn't living there i had i
had it was a 30 30 plus minute drive
um later on they expanded like the school got bigger and
bigger because they couldn't fit in the gated community so
they bought like other buildings the school like used to own
a like it used to own uh there was a building that was
supposed to be a mall and then the school bought it and then
it became like the middle school slash high school and they
had escalators and shit like that it was fucking crazy
because the school wasn't that building they bought for
middle slash high school was not even supposed to be a
school so they had like elevators and everything
escalators and they had like escalators and shit not
elevators escalators and stuff um, but anyway I thought it
was really funny like I thought I didn't think it was weird
back then because like um this was like one of the first
international schools I went to I didn't think it was weird
because like you know little dokey was like oh yeah it's
just it's like suburbia you know I was like, whoa, it's like
suburbia where there's like houses and stuff and like villas
and stuff where like all the like Americans so they don't
feel weird.
They don't feel like culture shock from living in Asia.
So basically what's so funny is that like all the students,
all like the, you know, all the students and the kids they
would go yes it was a gated community because like when you
had to enter the school to enter the community you need a
special pass to even like drop your kids off because they're
like we don't want kid you know they don't want kidnappers
to come in to like just pick because it's like there's
preschool as well there's preschool too so like they don't
want like you know some because there's like there's some
really rich people there because a lot of schools a lot of
people that go to like if they are like um because like a
lot of people that a lot of the adults that uh you know are
have to go to like Asia and stuff um and put their kids to
international school they're usually are working for like
really big companies and their companies sent them to like
certain Asian countries to like expand the company and stuff
like that so like you would see like you know executives
children and stuff like I had an actual Oh, what is it
called?
Like...
I had an actual Saudi princess that went to one of my
international schools.
Like, legitimately, she was a Saudi princess.
I'm not joking.
I am not joking.
Like, she was like...
I remember because she was like...
She was like my senior.
And...
She was like two years...
older than me and like uh and and like we had an event where
it was like secret santa we had an event that was like
secret santa and um and everyone was like oh my god her hair
is my secret santa i was like hoping she would be like their
secret santa because like i was like why does everyone want
her to want her to be like the secret santa and people like
bro she's like bro yo she's like fucking loaded she bought
okay they won't say fucking but they're like bro she's
loaded like she actually buys the most insane gifts for you
if you get her as a secret santa i was like bro like what
yeah one of them is like yeah bro don't she got me like a
pizza by
know why it was but like she gets like multiple presents for
a little oil yeah and then they're like yeah she like gives
you like beats by tray headphones and that was when like
beats by tray was like super popular by the way and and was
like and it was like and she and like it's not just that she
gets you more than she got me a designer bag and beats by
trays like someone was like i got her last year i got a
beats by tray and a designer bag from her god getting her as
a I remember I remember like talking to her and like her I
remember I don't know why I just remember like one point I I
was like talking to her and and she was like oh yeah when I
graduate um um because like you know she's literally like a
saudi princess apparently she's like yeah they got to you
know to go uh i actually have uh i actually have a biancé
like i was like and i was really young i was like in middle
school and she was like a high schooler so like to me i was
like a biancé i was like me thinking back i was like whoa
you're gonna get you're gonna get married after you graduate
like i was like i don't know i remember i was super young i
was in middle school like yeah and i was like wow do you
know who he is and she was like no like it was arranged and
i was and then you know i was young i didn't like think
about it
so that's crazy anyway as i was saying it was this this
international school i used to go to because i went to many
international schools like i traveled a lot uh growing up
because i had to move around a lot and um um um and like i
remember just like like to to even like enter the gated
community you need like a pass because you know people they
don't want to have their child kidnapped because we also
have like okay also i think it's just really bad poor
planning of the surroundings because the playground was very
near the entrance where all the little kids play on so like
i feel like maybe it was also Because there was, the
playground was practically almost at the entrance of the
community.
So yeah, you needed like a pass to even enter the entrance.
You needed a pass to like even enter the entrance and drop
your kid.
So like you need a special pass.
But yeah, for those, like I said, for those who don't know,
that's why I'm saying like a lot of people that...
That usually have, you know, a lot of the, especially like,
like Americans, the people who don't live, who don't live in
the country the international school is in, usually the
parents were, were assigned to work in that country, like as
an expat, and they were assigned to work in that country to
like help with expansion, you know, like, like expanding
into a new country for the business, for the company.
I remember like, I, one of them, one of my schools that I
went to, one of my international schools was like, I think
like six.
60 to 70 percent were like uh koreans uh because at that
time samson um samson was expanding their business uh in
this particular area so they sent a lot of like uh a lot you
know sent a lot of the uh a lot of koreans to this
particular region and so like you know their kids will go to
my school And then like 60 to 70% of the student body, yeah,
the Korean execs would be like, would like attend my school.
And so that's how I learned Korean because at that time, at
that time, I would, you know, I had a lot of friends, Korean
friends.
So that's how I learned a lot about like Korean culture,
like Korean K-pop and all that stuff.
Like I was like, you know, like now it's like BTS.
Super Junior, Big Band, stuff like that.
Like, Big Band was pre-BTS.
Before you guys had BTS, Big Band walked for you.
Big Band and Super Junior.
Super Junior and Big Band walked so BTS can run.
So, yeah, in 21, I don't know.
always i love to it to any i love i don't remember to
anyone's songs but like i remember like uh i just love the
name i thought it was like such a creative name um uh thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you doki went to
school with actual ojo no i did i one of okay so like in one
of okay so in one of my international schools there's like
i'll say it's so fucked up but like there's special tuition
for the for citizens of like whatever region i would like
whatever country i was in so like um because like
international schools have this so like usually
international schools is for international students but they
will make exceptions if you're really rich so like they will
they will make exceptions to like the local local in the
area if you're really rich they'll they'll have like jacked
up price tuition prices just for like um just for like the
locals in the area uh so like if you're international
student you would pay like you know one sixth of that price
but like um like or or you could say like if you're a local
you would pay the tuition for that for a year would be like
times six the original price So I remember there was a girl
in my grade.
I was in middle school.
There was a girl, I think, or like, was that in high school?
I'm trying to remember which school this was.
But there was a girl in my school.
And then I remember everyone was telling me, like, bro,
like, because, like, she, because, like, we would be like,
where are you from?
And then the girl would be like, oh, I'm here from here.
Like, because we would do, like, icebreakers being, like,
because we're all international.
We're all, like, quote-unquote, international students from
different countries.
so we'll be we'll do like icebreakers being like oh where
are you guys from like as your icebreaker like oh i'm from
i'm from ireland or like oh i'm from south africa uh stuff
like that and it should be like i'm from here so you know we
all thought it was weird
we were like how are you what do you mean here this is an
international school What do you mean you're from here?
And then I remember I was just like That's weird I remember
I was like That's weird This is an international school
And then I remember because like Bro she was She was fucking
loaded She was okay okay I don't know if this was like based
off of like how how much how rich she was but like whenever
we would have school trips or like trips where like
obviously like the places we're going it's like not a great
like you know like maybe we were going to travel somewhere
that was like community service or something we had to do
like community service in like um a different like area like
we had to like you know uh take a plane ride to a certain
area and we do community service or stuff like that she
would she i don't know how but like she would get like a
permission slip Being like, oh, I can't go, I'm sick.
She had to, like, avoid doing community service.
I was like, she literally being like, oh, I can't go, I'm
sick.
So, like, she would actually get, like, a note from
whatever.
Maybe, like, the doctors or something being, like, she can't
do community service or, like, that far because she's sick
and then she was obviously not sick because she would go to
school to give the slip to the teacher she would come to
school to like give the slip to the teacher and just because
we all have to show up at school to take the bus to or take
the bus or like take you take the shuttle bus to the airport
and then i remember one time i was actually sick um one time
like i was actually sick and i had to like and the thing is
it's not like you don't go to school uh you don't go to
school if you're like uh if you're like sick sick thing like
if you're not if you're not going to go do the trip you
still had to go to school and do like class work because
like it's technically a school event so um i think i think
it was sick i think like i twisted my ankle or something so
i still had to go to school i couldn't participate in one of
the community service trips so i had to i actually i
actually like twisted my ankle from like one of the sports i
did sports i did and so but i still had to like show up at
school because i couldn't do the community service thing so
i had to do And then, like, I see her.
I see her there, you know?
And we all had laptops, too.
So, like, when we're doing classwork, because, like, it was
me, her, and this other girl.
And I would, like, do classwork and stuff.
And then I look over to my...
Because we're all at the sit together.
And I look over to my side.
And I see her looking at, like, buying shopping.
I see her, like, online shopping and watching YouTube
videos.
she does not I call bullshit I call BS she was not sick she
was not sick I know being sick doesn't prevent you from
browsing the internet but there's no way she was sick every
time every time we had community service there's no fucking
way she would
Fucking wait.
Every time we had community service, she was fucking sick.
I refuse to believe it.
Oh my god.
But yeah, that I just, God, that was like such a memory for
me.
Oh yeah, and then, uh, we, it won't be just one
international school.
There was like, another international school.
Okay, it's so fucked up.
Really fucked up for me to say But we had a rival There was
a rival international School We had a rival international
School but our school Was the more expensive
Our school was the better Performing one It was the tuition
was more Expensive and like our students Performed better
like like we were we performed a lot better so so we had a
we would do like you know we would have like rival uh the
rival events and stuff so like also like to get in um
there's also like uh i know like uh it's also like a bit
more i think like i don't know how i oh wait i'm trying to
remember how i got in but like you had to take like tests
and stuff too um uh so like if you failed the entrance exam
for my school or you have the money because i know i know
there's i know damn well some of them there was no way they
would pass the entrance exam i don't i know there's some
people in my school there's no way they would pass the
entrance exam but they were loaded
Anyway, anyway, um, um, anyway, as I was saying, um, uh, so
there was the rival school and the rival international
school, and, like, we had, there was, like, a huge rivalry
between us two, because, you know, they're, they're,
they're, like, not that even far.
They're not, the funny thing is that like practices like uh
like sport practices like like like soccer or like soccer
practices there's only i think there's there's like only one
field there's only like one giant field and like and it's so
funny because and but there's like three there's like three
fields so so sometimes we would fight over which school gets
to use the field to school gets to use the field for like
soccer practice and we would be like oh there when we get to
the when we would get to like the field and we see them i
obviously i don't want to talk to anybody so i'll be like oh
there they are there's that school we'll be like oh my god
there they are
like actual school rivalry and shit and and we'll be oh and
then we will be like come and then i remember i remember
we'll be like at least we're not i'm gonna try to make a
name okay uh at least i'm gonna make up like letters i'll be
like uh at least we're not uh yot and stuff like that We'll
be like, oh my god, like, I can't believe this is happening
to us, but at least we don't go to YOT.
Because we're all, we were so pretentious.
Holy shit.
We were so pretentious because we always were like, our
school is better.
Because we'll be like, oh my god, at least we're not YOT.
And we'll be like, we have better facilities.
And then, and then, you know, the other school would be
like, oh my god, at least we're not like them, you're so
fucking pretentious.
We had, we had, there was like one, one person in, uh, not
me, I wouldn't say it, but like, these are like the things
I'd hear, like the things I hear and stuff.
And, um, cause like, okay, it's really, uh, when I did like
sports, when I did like, varsity sports i was one of the
only players in my team that would befriend other players in
different schools so like i would like hang i would actually
like befriend like other players in like uh different
schools and stuff so i had like i would just hang because i
don't know it was fun it was fun because it was like um an
international school so i can meet people from different
countries and i remember like when i was like i went to
soccer um i would always hang befriend like some of the
really good players uh from different school same with
volleyball uh and stuff and i would befriend like the
players from different school and hang out with them usually
uh i was a little bit of an outsider in my teams because i
usually uh usually i wouldn't hang out with my team all the
time and i would hang out with like uh the other players in
different teams and oh my god I remember I was like hanging
out with one of the rival teams because they had a really
really good player back then in one of the one of the in
soccer in one of my schools I was known as like one of the
best goalies in our division so like out of all the schools
I was like the best goalkeeper um versus like all the
schools during like because like we would have with a lot of
international schools from like different countries um so
like in one one time i was like the best goalkeeper in like
in in the division for like all the schools combined um but
but there was like this one girl who was an insane striker
like she was like the best um she was like the best striker
out of all the schools she was the best striker and i
befriended her bro she's so fucking good and then we would
like every time we meet up um because she goes from a
different school like she obviously she goes to
international school in a different country uh so like uh
every time we meet up in like a tournament like um we would
like practice against each other and stuff because like you
know if i practice against the best i can perform better
against the other strikers because she was known she
literally got like a She literally got a soccer scholarship,
uh, for university, like, because I, like, kept in touch
with her for a bit, but I don't talk, like, after, you know,
after, uh, university, like, obviously, like, you don't
really keep in touch with a lot of people, but, like, she,
she's so good that she got scouted overseas.
That's how good she was.
Like, like, usually scouting would happen, you know, in the,
in, in the country, but she literally got scouted overseas
for a soccer scholarship.
That's how insane she was.
she was as a striker and like her entire family were like
was obsessed with soccer because like I would I think I was
at the school for like two to three years so um a year
passed and then her little sister uh was in the division and
she was also a goalkeeper and that became friends with her
too because uh uh because uh you know I was like oh you're
you're her sister and then you're also a goalkeeper so then
we would like i would give her like tips and advice on like
being a goalkeeper and stuff like that like uh so like uh
like her entire family was just really talented at soccer um
i remember it was a crazy moment she kicked me in the head
the striker because we were like we were facing them so and
um that's where i lost a bit of my brain cells but Like,
obviously I had, like, I, like, protected my head because,
like, I dived over and, like, grabbed the ball and, like,
huddled around it.
Because I, I aggressed her.
I pushed her.
Like, it was a huge damper, and I pushed her.
I aggressed her, and then, like, I, like, covered my head
with my arms or stuff, but she still, like, hit me.
I kept playing.
um but yeah no I usually um I like hang out with the uh I
hang out with like I said I usually just hang out yeah yeah
she was like oh my gosh I'm so sorry like uh like I said I
usually hang out with like the players from the rival teams
because I thought it was like I thought it was cool I
thought it was fun hanging out with like people I don't
normally like taught like I'm don't like I have a rare
chance to meet up with and stuff like that and um and it was
like a fun moment being able to meet like with people from
uh with people from like different countries and stuff um
let's see I'm trying to like remember uh fuck it was like
how did I get to this part of the story oh yeah yeah yeah
anyway about rival schools so like one time one time there
was there was a guy in our class who left our school to go
to the rival school
because because like he was like because we had a teacher
there that like I guess like made fun of him too much
because he was like the class clown he was the class clown
in her class and then I think he didn't really like when he
didn't like one of the teachers he really hated one of the
teachers which is understandable we all we had a teacher
that everybody hated we hated her and she was like our math
teacher and the thing is like nobody liked her nobody liked
her she was our math teacher nobody liked her but thing is
her husband is also a math teacher as well um but we all
love the husbands the husband um because he was a really
good teacher but the but the other teacher we hated her
anyway one of our one of the our the the guys in the guy in
their class really hated the the the math teacher the the
wife really hated the wife because she was like really mean
she was so mean and she graded really harshly
And at one point, sometimes the teacher would follow the
grade, like get a promotion.
They would get a promotion, and we would have to see them
again the year after.
So when he found out that she's going to follow us, like
she's going to be this teacher for the grade above, he left
our school and went to the rival school.
And I remember our class feeling so betrayed.
We'll be like I can't believe he went to UOT I'll be like Oh
my god he's a UOT Student now He's okay like I'm gonna make
up a mascot Cause we also have like school mascots And he's
like he's a fucking tiger now Yeah Yeah Yeah I just I'm just
like remembering that part of my life and I was like holy
holy shit oh okay I can talk about this without really like
doxing anybody so like you know um like I say I would um I
go to international schools um around the world not around
the world sorry around Asia sorry uh around Asia but
obviously at one point I went to an international school uh
I went to and and I I used to live in uh Hong Kong and one
of my favorite and like during like the tournament circuit
there was one school that I loved seeing this was like one
of my favorite schools that I loved uh that i loved seeing
when facing during tournaments and uh and like i was so
happy i was so like whenever like whenever this school
hosted tournaments i loved that school because i just and it
was i don't remember the name but like this international
school is like well known in well known in hong kong and
it's primarily australians It was literally an international
school just for Australians and it was so cool.
It was actually so cool Yeah, yeah, I mean and then like I
remember cuz like every time they would do a school cheer
They'd be like ah see ah see ah see oh oh And then I would
do their cheer because that shit was so cool It's like ah
see oh ah see oh ah see oh Every time I fucking love that
shit.
I would like cheer with them because it was such a good
cheer
So um and and I like that shit was so fire I I loved like um
I loved like uh just like competing against them or
competing like going to your school whenever like they
hosted tournaments and stuff because it was i just i don't
know it was just so fun like australians are so fucking fun
i like how someone's like every international private school
wait i like them i thought they were funny i thought the
sports teams were funny okay maybe like the regular students
might have been like might have been too much but the sports
team students were funny though but yeah i like them but
there was an international school in in hong kong that was
just australians um and it was like you know obviously like
kangaroos and stuff like that like the entire mascots were
uh kangaroos and stuff uh and you know they were pretty i
thought they were pretty cool i thought the sports teams
were pretty cool guys i thought i don't know the regular
students but the athletes there were we're we're we're we're
we're fun they were fun to hang out with i hanged with them.
They had the worst kids.
But the, bro, I hung out with the sport team, though.
They were so fun.
I don't know about the regular sports.
students
but yeah I don't know international school is so different I
mean I went from like a private Catholic school to like a
private Catholic school in Canada and then like I had to
obviously move out of Canada and do international schools
around Asia so so um so like i never had like a regular
school experience i think um i never really had like a
regular oh yeah i was like one of the few students there
that was not catholic or christian i don't know i don't know
the difference between christian christian and catholic um i
don't know the difference between christian or catholic i
either went to a private catholic school or a private
christian school i don't remember maybe catholic catholic
sounds like some like something said a lot um but uh uh but
like uh so like in canada i used to go to like a private
catholic school um but i was like one of the few students
that was not catholic or like baptized so like i was
excluded with like religious events i told this story before
but like um there would be like like religious events and
stuff where you have to be baptized to participate so if
you're not baptized you have to do school work you have to
be like locked in like not locked in a classroom but like
all the unbaptized kids would be like kept in the classroom
to do school class work and then and then i would get so
jealous because i would be like i want to because then and
we really young, you know, because I was like in primary
school.
So then I was like, it's not fair.
I want to go to confession two with everyone.
I remember I'd be like, I want to go to confession two.
I didn't know what was going on.
I was just like, it's not fair why did they get to do stuff
and i had to be locked in i had to be in the classroom to do
classwork and then so like and then we would have like
friday mass um we would have friday mass you know and then
like every before we start the day and then obviously you're
baptized you can go in the front and eat bread from the the
pope will give you like some fucking bread thing.
Are those bread?
I don't know.
I never got to try it because I was not baptized.
So, so you know how they handle those circular things you
get to eat?
So they're like, all the baptized students get to line up
and get to line up and you get to eat that little special,
like circular communion, communion wafers.
And obviously I wasn't baptized, so I didn't get to up and
I'll be like it's not fair what might not baptize they all
get to eat those cool they look so cool for I felt so
excluded I felt so fucking excluded I'd be like it's not
fair why don't I get to why don't I get to yeah I had FOMO I
I had FOMO as a child that's how fucked up it was um i'll be
like what does it taste like why do they it's not fair i
don't get to line up for it like they do and then and then
obviously you know i'm not catholic because my family's not
religious so um we would have i don't remember what what the
religious event was and yeah i got fomoed from not getting
the circle bread uh so and i remember because you know how
like those like of those beads called the the rosemary's and
then obviously like all the students who are like actually
religious they will have their very own rosemary's and stuff
and a rosary sorry rosaries sorry rosaries they would have
the rosary beads um and then and then I didn't I didn't know
I didn't get to try it I just saw everybody lining up and
getting it every Friday so I got foam So anyway, the rosary
beads, and like obviously, like, since you're not baptized,
you don't have the pretty rosary beads.
So they give us the plastic blue ones.
So like, we all, the unbaptized sinners will get the
non-believers, get the plastic blue rosaries.
And then my friends surrounding me, they would get like the
really pretty custom ones because they...
Why does everyone have the pretty necklace, but not me?
I felt so ashamed.
It's actually crazy going to, like, this Catholic school.
I felt so ashamed not being Catholic.
It's like, I felt like, I'll be like, why don't I get all
this?
And I remember one time, I'll be like, Mom, I want to get
baptized, Mom.
I remember once I like asked my mom that I want to get
baptized because I wanted to eat the I really wanted to go
to confession I know what was actually going on I had no
idea what was actually going on I just felt like I just had
phone mode the fear I got left out so like I was just like I
want to be I was like it's not fair I want to go to
confession I don't know what the fuck
I just wanted to go!
That's how they get you, the FOMO.
Yes, I almost, I almost got baptized because of FOMO, but
then my mom was like, what the fuck is wrong?
I mean, like, you're not getting baptized because you're a
FOMO, because you're scared of being left out.
It doesn't mean, you gotta, you really wanna get baptized.
It has to be an actual choice from you, not because of FOMO.
because it was obviously I didn't know what the fuck was
going on
um Michael they give us super chat thank you thank you damn
unbaptized kids literally got what the fuck thank you thank
you thank you um yeah I had to I need baptized for the right
reasons not because of FOMO not because I was I felt like I
felt I felt sad of being left out because I didn't get the
special wafers like
um super thank you for the super chat thank you thank you as
a catholic myself i apologize on behalf of him for such
discrimination and oh thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you oh yeah okay what was funny is that the the
Catholic school the private Catholic school I went to was
super competitive to get in but I literally got in via
nepotism I think I told this story before but I literally
got in because um one of my cousins I think like one of my
cousins or uh or like I think yeah one of my uh my mom's
like friends kids or cousins or whatever um she used to go
to this was like straight A student, like one of their best
performing student.
So then they were like, wait, Joki is related to her?
Oh my god, that's all right, you don't have to take the
test.
They thought, they thought I was gonna be the next her.
They're like, she doesn't need to take the test, she's in.
Because it was like super competitive and you have to take a
test and everything.
But because I was like related to her, one of their best
students I didn't need to take a test instead when I got in
after like um I think that was a mistake for them because in
like two to three years they put me in an ESL class
by the way English is my first language but in two to three
years I got put in an ESL class
I didn't understand the concept of the okay the main reason
why I got put in ESL class is because I didn't understand
the concept of paragraphs and and the reason being is that I
took the instructions so literal so um I was like the one
person that actually like got kicked out of ESL class after
like two years they kicked me out of ESL class because
they're like wait you're not actually ESL you can wait you
you don't have to go to this anymore so basically what
happened was that um we were told that paragraphs um they
have to be if you want to make a paragraph you have to like
make sure that it's around the same same topic and uh and
usually it's like five to seven sentences uh oh wait not
three to four okay i heard five i heard five okay it could
be four to five four to five sentences so i latched on to
the four to five sentences part i didn't care i didn't care
what the topic was each paragraph i like counted my
sentences and i was like one two three four five all right
next paragraph one two three four five next paragraph and
then they me into ESL class because I kept doing that I kept
I kept counting my paragraphs I did I latched on to that for
some reason and also I quote okay to be fair I also
sometimes I okay no that wasn't part of ESL class no no it
was that it was 100% that because the moment like we had the
lessons about paragraphs they put me in ESL class like right
after I don't I it had to be that because right after the
lesson about paragraphs I got put into ESL um and then one
or two years later like they kicked me out of ESL because
they're like wait you're not actually ESL like you you're
able to learn the other stuff well uh so so I got kicked out
after that.
I was like the only student in my, like, because there was
like, you know, there was like several, there was like three
other kids, three to four other kids that was in like ESL,
but like I was literally the only one that graduated ESL
class.
Because I realized I shouldn't be there.
Um, thank you for the super chat thingy thing.
you um uh and squibbly thank you the super chat thank you
thank you dukey gate cat from grace thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you yeah that was like that was a wild
time it was such a wow um lord crosses thank you for the
akasupa thank you thank you my oh she is so stupid she's the
best i love her so much it's great i'm like relayed You
watch me so you can feel like mentally superior You're like,
man, I'm stupid But at least I'm not that stupid Getting put
in ESL just because she can't She can't count paragraphs
Um Um Dark Blade, thank you for the super chat Thank you,
thank you I remember you said once you play center for
basketball i still find it crazy for your height that's cool
as a basketball fan also unrelated but you get yes i got the
gifts from anime north um there's like a lot of letters also
uh speaking of like uh gifts at conventions um if you want
me to um if you are okay with me talking about your letters
or like talking about stuff about your gifts please feel
free to like write something down to say like oh you have
permission to talk about it on stream because i don't want
to talk about something you know if it was like a private
gift and you don't want it to be called talk about on stream
um i don't want to talk about it just because like i'm
worried about like you know privacy issues for you guys so
like if you really want me if you're okay with me to talk
about it on stream just feel free to write in the letter and
say that you're okay with it being talked about on stream
and yeah yeah i was literally put in center for basketball
um because uh because i
I was like, I played center position, but I was like, I
should not have been center position.
It was so sad because when I first tried it for basketball
for one of the teams, when I first tried it for basketball,
the person that was centered for the team, like, you know,
she was like a senior well i wouldn't say senior it was
middle school so like i would be sixth grade and she'll be
like an eighth grader and then i tried out for the
basketball team in sixth grade and like obviously i had to
compete with the eighth grade center but i can jump higher
than her so like it doesn't it didn't matter and she was
american so like obviously she was taller than me
was a short Asian kid and she was American.
And so, so she was, she had some height on me.
She was a lot taller than me.
I'll just tell you that.
She was definitely a lot taller than me.
But she was coasting.
The thing is, she coasted.
And the coach used me against her.
to like, because she was like, oh, I'm tall.
I don't have to jump, you know?
Like, that's her mindset.
I remember this.
Her mindset was like, oh, I'm tall.
I don't need to jump.
I'm fucking taller than the girls here.
I can literally just like reach my head out and just go, you
know, and like hit the ball in the center position.
But like, the thing is, I jumped higher.
I could jump really high.
And like me jumping really high, I could grab the ball.
I could like hit the ball before she could squat it with her
height.
So basically, when I was first trying out the team, the
coach was like, oh, what position?
I was like, I don't care.
I need position.
And then the coach realized I could jump really high and
they could grab rebounds and stuff.
And so like, she was like, wait, you want to try to center?
We're going to have like a, like, five on five we're gonna
put her me on center and then like obviously the the actual
team center like the main center because like she's been the
center for like two years because like she's an eighth
grader like we're gonna fight against her so i'm a fucking
sixth grader fighting against a really tall american who's
been on the team for like two years already who's been the
center and then i was like what the fuck i think i'm
literally i was like what the fuck why is i'm like
I'm trying out Like I'm here to try out And the thing is
Obviously I was motivated You know I was very motivated And
I was like Okay God I fucking try And I was able to You know
Every time I swatted the ball I was able to like Swat the
ball Before her And then Oh I felt so bad for her Cause the
coach was like Was like Cause the coach used me As like Like
an example And she was like Like, see?
She's able to grab the ball before you.
She's a sixth grader who jumps and actually wants it.
Because, like, the other girl was coasting.
Because she thought nobody was going to fucking get it.
Anyway, I took center position from her.
I ended up taking...
becoming a starter.
I became the starter five and got into the team.
And I took center from her.
In sixth grade, I became a starter.
Alright, thank you.
Rich, I thank you.
Doki will never be balling.
Doki She's fucking bawling.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Because the other player, the other player, she coasted and
like never got, like, never got better enough.
Because I would always like, um, um, I was like always,
like, I was very determined in, like, being the best.
Um, by the way, I hated basketball.
By the way.
The other part of the story was that I hated basketball.
Like it was, I didn't like hate, hate basketball.
But like out of all the sports I tried out for, basketball
was my least favorite.
My most favorite was soccer and volleyball.
I loved soccer and volleyball the most.
Basketball was at the lowest here.
But like at that time, I was trying out for all the sports.
Because it's like per season.
But, like, I knew, and I was really good at basketball.
Like, uh, and I was, like, really good at it.
So that's why, like, I played basketball because I knew I
was really good at it.
And I was super, I'm still super competitive.
And the funny thing is, I became the captain of the
basketball team.
Um, at one point.
It was my least favorite sport, but I was the captain of the
basketball team.
not in sixth grade though not in sixth grade
but like I would always be like I hate I don't like the
basketball guy I just never enjoyed basketball as much as
the other sports but I knew I was good at it because I had
really good hand-eye coordination I always had like really
good hand-eye coordination and um um and like uh and like
and so like i just like playing a lot of sports and that's
why i'm really good at fps because i have good hand-eye
coordination oh my god one time one of my math teachers who
was like a coach of i don't know i think he was like he was
like i think he was a volleyball coach and he like like
after because i had a class i had like he was like one of my
like grade teachers like not math teacher he was like the
grade teacher uh for us like the homeroom teacher and i
remember because i like at one point i was like coasting
because i knew i was good at hand eye coordination and i was
coasting and stuff like i didn't i knew because at that
point i was like oh yeah whatever like i know like i'm the
best player uh i know like i'm really good and um i remember
like my homer teacher pulled me aside and was like no
because they were they were like a volleyball coach they
were they were a really good volleyball coach and they were
like aside and was like was like um uh i don't remember what
he said he was like he pulled me aside after class to talk
about like sports like talk about like i think volleyball or
something it was either volleyball season or soccer season
and he was like look dokey like we know you have really good
hand-eye coordination but you could be better you could be
so much better
I was just like, what the fuck?
He put his eyes like, if you train harder, you could be the
very best.
Like, you have really good hand-eye coordination.
You have so much potential.
I was like, what the?
I remember I was like, I was like, I think I was in middle
school and I was just like, oh, what the fuck, guys?
I didn't know what to say.
I was already on the volleyball team that's the thing I was
already bro no volleyball fucked up my arm um I was a really
talented volleyball player uh because in sixth grade I was
able to do overhand serves um and that was like a huge like
skill to have as a sixth grader so like because like they
were teaching us normal serving and then they were and i was
like oh i want to do i want to learn like i would see people
doing overhand serves like oh i want to learn overhand
serving so like in sixth grade i learned how to do overhand
serving while all the other sixth graders were doing
underhand serving so like and then on the team i was like
really good at like serving my serves were insane um and uh
to the point where one time like i would be put as the
starter server that was like my position because i could do
overhand serves as a sixth grader and like my serves are
very hard to hit apparently because like they were saying
that when i serve the ball doesn't move the ball i don't
know how to say it the the ball doesn't spin and people were
saying that it's so hard to hit because the ball didn't spin
when i hit it you hit the ball so I don't know how I did it
I just fucking hit the ball like I don't know
so whenever I serve because like I don't know why they
couldn't hit it but they were like bro the ball doesn't move
they were like it doesn't move when you serve that's like so
like this is how I was starting server and I would hit I
would get our team 10 to 15 points um I literally one I
remember two of the schools we faced I would be put at
starting server and I would get like 10 plus points off the
bat by just serving it was so sad it was so sad I would get
like 10 plus points by serving only because I was put as the
starter And then, like, I'd just be like, boop, boop, boop,
and then, like, it was so fucking sad.
And, and, I think, like, it was either 7th grade or 8th
grade.
I fucked up my arm because my coach, um, do you need 25?
One time I got, like, 20 points.
I remember now.
I couldn't remember the maximum.
I think I remember one time I got 20 points in a row against
a team.
And I fucked up my arm in, like, either 7th or 8th.
grade because my coach really wanted it was like my coach
really wanted to win against this one game and i sprained my
i had muscle aches on my arm to the point where like the
coach all the coach did was like they applied cream to it or
something like muscle i don't know what kind of cream to it
and ever since that day i couldn't do those serves anymore
um because it like messed up like i overstrained it so much
from it that like i couldn't do the strain my career ended
so no no I wouldn't say my career ended so fast because I
could still serve but I couldn't do that that that serve
anymore like I couldn't do that serve anymore um I it was so
bad like it was like one tournament it was one tournament uh
where I lost the power I think it was eighth grade it was
eighth grade I think so because it was like two years I was
like known as the best server in eighth grade for one of the
tournaments, I fucked up my arms so much that I couldn't do
that serve anymore.
I think if I do, I think if I trained again, if I could have
trained again and try and replicate again, maybe I would
have been able to grab that, been able to do it again, but I
was just natural.
It was a natural thing I did, like a natural talent.
Because literally in sixth grade, I could just do overhead.
stuff um yeah you're the legendary player that retired after
getting over it oh they patched my exploit guys there was a
new patch guys there was a new patch we got joki 2 op must
nerf um they They did.
I was too good Yeah, I got nerfed IRL.
They patched me out Bro, the people hated Bite bursting.
They hated Like, the thing is The thing is I could do
whatever the floating shit you were saying Like the whatever
when you guys were calling My serve like the floating
whatever I could do that in underhand The funniest part was
that I couldn't do it overhand anymore So I started doing it
underhand And I could do the float serve.
Like, I could do it on underhand as well.
Um, so sometimes, like, if I had to, I would use underhand
serve to, like, guarantee it.
Because I knew how, um, I knew how to do it underhand, like,
underhand serve.
But, because, like, uh, I don't know.
I just remember, like, we got, like, eight, like, 10 points
from it.
Because, like, it was, like, around that time, like, uh, we
were down.
I remember it would we were down like uh we were down uh it
was like I think it was like 20 to like 10 or something it
was like 20 to 10 and then it was my turn to serve obviously
I couldn't do overhead anymore because like I it was the
thing is I think like it was like the turn it was a
tournament after I fucked up my arm so it was a tournament
after I fucked up my arm and the thing We had to win this
game to head to the semi-finals.
Because, like, it was such a weird bracket.
It was, like, first versus fourth.
Oh, I remember.
Oh, my God.
It was such a really happy memory for me.
Because it was first place versus fourth place team.
My school was the fourth place team.
And, um, and, like, obviously, we weren't guaranteed to...
We weren't going to...
We thought we weren't going to win it because we're fourth
place.
and like we're up against like you know the the the main
team no and the main team that was first place and and we
win it we had to the semi-finals we would be playing as
first versus second so we'll do like we'll head straight to
the semi-finals and play first versus second and like i
remember it was like 20 20 to 10 and then i was up and i
ended up getting i remember i got 14 points with underhand
serve because my overhand at that time was not consistent
anymore because I would sometimes hit the net because I
fucked up my arm um so I ended up getting but it was one set
the thing is we had to play two sets I got us the first set
from that and then we won the second set because the first
place team was so sad I remembered because the first place
and I got MVP I got, because, like, MVP was chosen by all
the coaches.
Like, every coach nominates, like, each player from each
school to get MVP.
And I got MVP for that.
Like, because all the coaches nominated me as MVP.
And we crushed their morale by winning the first set that we
won the second set.
We were so happy.
We got second place because we were not good enough for
first.
We were not, we were just...
just happy to be second we were so surprised we're like
because we were not supposed to be there we were happy just
to be second because we did not or we did not win the semis
we got like too old so fast but like but i did the underhand
serve the first set i did the underhand serve and it was a
floater um it like the ball didn't move it literally the
ball didn't spin so like i remembered and i got like 14
points from just serving because i was like oh guys i was
like i'm not gonna risk it guys i'm not gonna risk overhand
serving we need these points i'm gonna do my underhand next
day thank you for the super chat thank you thank you you're
my favorite sports anime protagonist thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you i tell you i used to do this it's
it's why i'm like good at hand-eye coordination because i
used to do a lot of sports back then growing up from like
middle school to high school um so like i had just had it
was an easy transition to play like fps games um but yeah we
were so happy for second place like we literally don't we
were like oh but we were not supposed to be here we were we
were not supposed to be here.
Bite size.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No wonder you can't read.
God had to nerve you in some way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I mean, it was like, it was fun.
I love, I love doing it.
I think like a lot of my happiest memories were just back
then in middle of high school were just like the sports that
I used to play.
Because it was fun.
I loved, I loved being competitive.
You know, like, I never realized how good I was at sports
until fifth grade.
In Canada, I didn't really do sports.
We just had PE classes.
We didn't have, like, actual, like, sports teams.
I mean, because we're in, like, elementary school, you know?
We were in elementary school.
And the only reason why I got into sports is that in fifth
grade, fifth grade is when I actually went to international
school, around.
And obviously it was still elementary elementary school
fifth grade.
And I remember we had like an after school activity where we
could sign up for several, where we signed up for several
after school activities.
One of them was soccer.
And then I would just like, you know, I was one of the few
girls that signed up for soccer, all the other guys, all the
other kids there were guys and sometimes there'd be like
middle schoolers there too so it was like super intimidating
and stuff and um in fifth grade our goalie we would do like
we would do like uh uh uh we would do like scrims and stuff
like we would do like scrims um uh where we'd play like
soccer and stuff and then i would play like as like defense
or uh offense I played defense or offense and then on the
last day our goalkeeper wanted to play offense and they told
me they're like okay come through goalkeeper on the last day
of the on the last day of the after-school activity and from
there I I caught majority of the shots and that's when I
knew I was had really good hand-eye coordination and like I
would I could be a really good goalkeeper and the coach
there after the games the coach there was like was like you
should try out for the soccer team in middle school when you
like for the year after like like when you get to sixth
grade you should try out for the soccer team like you should
really try out for your goalkeeper
because i caught majority of the shots and um the Thing was
that, um, um, The thing was that, like, uh, We were playing
against, like, middle schoolers, too, so it was, like, um,
like, fifth graders with middle schoolers, too.
And, um, I really, and then I had a really fun time.
I was like, wait, soccer is pretty fun.
Because, like, before then, I was just like, um, you know, I
was just like, yay, kickball, yay!
You know, I was a fucking fifth grader.
But it wouldn't be, like, well, I love soccer.
I was just like, yay!
Kickball!
And then...
Uh...
And then there was...
And then, like, I swapped the goalkeeper.
I was like, wait!
This is fun!
Wait a minute!
Soccer can be really fun!
And that's when I started doing...
And from there, I started participating in, like, when I hit
to middle school, I started doing, like, like, everything
changed when I got to be a goalkeeper.
And then I started really enjoying, like, sports because it
was, like, I had an enjoyment out of it.
I think when I was in, I would, like, I really like being
goalkeeper.
I don't know.
I just like catching balls.
Like, I don't know.
It's just fun.
It's just my goal kick was...
I had an insane goalie kick.
So, like, you know when you get the ball and you kick it as
a goalie and you can do, like, the punt, my punt would
literally go all the way to the other goalie.
Like, yeah, like, I would kick the ball and it would, and,
like, when, you know, like, the, the punt, not the, like,
ground shot, like, the, the punt kick.
way to the other goalkeeper so i had to like control it
because if i just kick it it just goes all the way then and
the other because i've done that a few times i didn't know
how to control it because i would just kick it to because i
was just like get it as far as possible because you grab the
ball and then you kick it so i was like get it as far as
possible so that i would just kick it and then we just head
to the other side and then go other side goalkeeper just
pick it up me be like what the fuck and this was in sixth
grade this was in sixth grade and and then i had to learn
how to control control where i actually like like kick it to
the i would kick it to the other side near the goalkeeper
but not to the goalkeeper i remembered because i would like
kick it to the goalkeeper would catch it and be like what
the fuck because people would be like why is it
um um and then yeah and then so i have to learn how to like
actually kick it to a player instead of like kicking it as
far as i can um uh but that i i miss soccer i miss soccer
and volleyball soccer and volleyball was my favorite sports
of all time uh broken bond thank you for the super chat
Thank you, thank you.
Are you the cats at a Mario House?
Sports, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just enjoyed sports.
I enjoyed it since middle school.
All the way to high school.
I really enjoyed playing sports.
It's just fun.
I was a very competitive person.
Oh my God.
I, whoa, it's almost two hours.
I yack for so long.
Oh my gosh.
It's almost two hours.
Holy shit.
I have fun time.
Talking to you guys today.
I'm gonna call it here because tomorrow.
Tomorrow there's an announcement stream.
And VR chat.
So I'm really looking forward to it.
I'm really looking forward to explore.
Explore VR chat worlds with you guys.
And like just.
Just have fun with all of you.
Anyway guys.
I'll also have an announcement at the end of the stream.
So please if you want to.
If you want to like.
You know what the announcement is.
You gotta stick around to the end guys.
we guys get excited for tomorrow bite size thank you for the
50 gift and chips thank you thank you holy shit thank you
that's so much thank you so much guys uh dark blade thank
you for the super chat thingy thank you by the way yeah full
100 permission to talk about my gift and letter if you want
i really hope you liked them thank you thank you for the
super chat thingy thank you i really appreciate it uh bite
size thanks for the yapping before bed it's gonna it's good
to have it back thank you the super chat thank you thank you
yeah i want to make this like i said i want to make this a
consistent series this series was postponed for a little bit
because um we had techin then a techin then wrestle tuber
then minecraft back to back to back so there was so much
stuff to do there was so much stuff to do but the series is
back now unless i get in get busy but yeah it's a fun time
yapping with all you guys i had a great time i'm always so
busy behind the but it's always nice to do a stream for you
guys or just hang out and talk because I really enjoy
talking with all of you guys and I hope you guys have a nice
rest or like a nice morning for work or school.
Good afternoon.
Hey, Tengen!
Hey, I was just about to end it.
But yes, guys.
I'll see you guys next time.
I'll see you guys tomorrow, everybody.
As always, everyone, say hi, J-Data, posture check.
Get up move around to get that blood flowing and if you sit
up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you
guys next time everybody bye guys bye